let's look at going between
representations we'll start in the ijk
representation going to the magnitude
and angle representation so if we have
our vector the arbitrary vector can be
written as ax I hat plus a YJ hat in
this particular case were given a vector
minus 2 I hat plus 3 J hat I would like
to go to the magnitude and angle
representation so first of all let's
draw it out on our grid like this and
let's find the magnitude so the
magnitude we can find through the
Pythagorean theorem it's just the square
root of the X component squared plus the
Y component squared and now we can find
the angle the angle the tangent of the
angle is just equal to the Y component
divided by the X component like this and
so in this way we can solve for the
angle
now let's practice going back the other
way if we're given a vector whose
magnitude is two and whose angle from
the x-axis is 30 degrees like this one
here then the X component is just the
magnitude times the cosine of the angle
so two times the cosine of 30 and the Y
component is just the magnitude times
the sine of the angle so two times the
sine of 30